[Música]
y
bienvenidos a francia enfocó su programa
sobre la actualidad francesa en esta
edición hablaremos de la mea culpa de la
iglesia católica gala por los casos de
abuso sexual a menores en los últimos 70
años tendremos como invitada a una mujer
que forma parte de uno de los colectivos
de víctimas de estos crímenes luego nos
centraremos en el alcohol y de 19 con la
pandemia se impusieron los gestos
barrera pero aquí los franceses parecen
cada vez menos proclives a respetar
estas reglas y terminaremos hablando de
un toque gastronómico del jamón viaje sé
que eso que durante décadas figuró como
el favorito en la mesa de los franceses
sin embargo este año perdió su lugar
número uno les contaremos por qué
comencemos nuestro programa por el
anuncio de la iglesia católica francesa
que va a vender parte de sus bienes para
indemnizar a las víctimas de pederastia
la medida fue tomada por la conferencia
episcopal a francesa durante su reunión
en lourdes a comienzos del mes de
noviembre pero también esto forma parte
de la respuesta al informe publicado en
el mes de octubre un informe de una
comisión independiente según el cual más
de 330.000 menores de edad han sido
víctimas de abuso sexual en el seno de
la iglesia desde los años 50 en el país
acaban de anunciar las primeras
decisiones de la iglesia un mes después
de la publicación del informe sobre
sobre los abusos sexuales la conferencia
episcopal francesa anunció la creación
de un organismo nacional independiente
de reconocimiento y reparación que será
dirigido por una jurista me agitaron de
hbo que son ex defensora de menores
salud le
proporcionaremos los medios para cumplir
esta misión de reconocimiento y
reparación en particular la
indemnización individualizada de las
víctimas cada una según sea necesario
para esto la iglesia no recurrir a las
donaciones de los fieles sino un fondo
de compensación creado en septiembre que
será financiado con las aportaciones de
los obispos la venta de inmuebles y
préstamos si es necesario la
indemnización afectaría a todas las
víctimas incluidas aquellas cuyo caso
haya prescrito a los ojos de la justicia
es el caso de nicola calvert ya no vale
ambos víctimas de un cura pederasta para
quienes este es el primer paso aunque la
iglesia debe comprometerse de forma
mucho más concreta
si me sometieron a un procedimiento de
tipo judicial no tendría ninguna de
éxito porque no podría probar todo no
tengo ninguna prueba no se trata sólo de
una compensación se trata de un
reconocimiento y de reconocer que sí que
algo pasó que debe ser reparado hoy
hay que entender que cuando eres víctima
vives de día en día pero vivirás soy
consciente de ello sé que moriré con
ello está la atrocidad absoluta que es
difícil de imaginar y eso efectivamente
esta dimensión de la reparación
financiera para mí es importante por el
momento la conferencia episcopal
francesa no ha dado una estimación del
monto de la indemnización nos acompaña
yo lo he fallado la tuya es miembro del
colectivo de la pago de los act y
holanda gracias por estar con nosotros
gracias mi primera pregunta es hoy a
este anuncio de la indemnización de las
víctimas pero está también esta parte
que tiene que ver con la reparación con
la iglesia que acepta su responsabilidad
como institución que más gestos están
esperando ustedes por parte de la
iglesia
la responsabilidad institucional de
allegri se pasa por toda la
responsabilidad institucional de la
iglesia es muy importante es como la
primera etapa ineludible para obtener el
resto la segunda noticia importante y
positiva es la creación de una instancia
para censar acoger e indemnizar a todas
las víctimas
precisamente otro de los anuncios es
también la creación de estos grupos de
trabajo uno de ellos enfocado en porque
se producen tantos casos de abuso sexual
en la iglesia porque ha sido tan difícil
poder identificar y detener a los
depredadores sexuales
ya de facto activo lógicos de ayala hay
factores teológicos es decir la
comprensión de dios y de la institución
hay factores más sociológicos se podría
decir la manera en la que se reclutan y
forman los curas hay una decisión
fundamental y es que se considera que
los curas lo sagrado está en manos de
los hombres luego hay también un
discurso bastante pernicioso que se
mantuvo durante mucho tiempo que quería
hacer creer a toda la sociedad y
principalmente a los curas y a los
laicos de que no se trataba sino de
casos aislados y que usted cree de
caicedo y hay otro de los puntos que
está dentro de lo que usted también
acaba de mencionar y tiene que ver con
el secreto de confesión que allí está
ese ese problema entre el derecho
canónico y el derecho penal y ambos lo
tienen como un secreto profesional pero
en el caso por ejemplo del derecho penal
pues éste no se aplica en caso de que
haya un abuso sexual o una mutilación
sexual sobre una menor de edad como
lograr de alguna manera que estas dos
visiones del derecho de estos dos
derechos de alguna manera compaginarse
y el hecho de que exista un secreto
profesional que no esté sometido a las
reglas del derecho francés
hasta que se cuestione sobre cómo se
percibe a sí misma la institución de
manera digamos colectiva y también
social es la única institución que en
sus fundamentos en su manera de ser y de
entenderse como institución se considera
por encima de la ley que es justo en
este punto en donde hay perversidad un
poder sin contrapoder sólo puede ser
abusiva
gracias por habernos acompañado
continuemos nuestro programa hablando
esta vez de comida 19 los saludos de
besos los abrazos los apretones de mano
todos estos gestos de cariño pero
también de formalidad quedaron
proscritos por cuenta de la pandemia sin
embargo a pesar de que el número de
casos está repuntando en francia como en
buena parte de europa los franceses
parecen cada vez menos respetar los
gestos barreras
codos rodillas un saludo de lejos desde
hace 19 meses convivimos con los gestos
barrera pero se siguen respetando
durante el coronavirus uno en realidad
saludaba solo con el codo o cosas así y
ahora saludo de besos sistemáticamente
cuando veo a alguien estamos un poco
menos preocupados digamos que ahora
tenemos la vacuna en cuanto a las
mascarillas y me relajé pero siempre
tengo cuidado en las tiendas respete lo
que se me pide el gerente de esta tienda
parisina constata cada día esta laxitud
el 95% entra con las mascarillas y al 5%
tengo que llamarle la atención y en
cuanto al gel creo que la mitad ya no lo
usa
y cuando llega la noche en lille todo
está permitido o casi saludo de beso en
la mejilla a este hombre a este hombre a
este hombre a esas personas como si
fuera necesario compensar todos los
besos que no dimos el saludo de beso
está regresando según un estudio hecho
en francia el 65% de los franceses se
saludan de beso casi el doble que hace
seis meses es cierto que hemos vuelto a
la vida social de antes abrazos besos
etcétera y es un placer francamente
somos muy malos con los gestos barrera
pero todos estamos vacunados
pero cuidado las vacunas no protegen
totalmente del contagio para algunos
especialistas hay que seguir con los
gestos barrera y las mascarillas deben
utilizarse en interiores en los espacios
abiertos de las empresas en los
auditorios en las aulas universitarias
en los transportes públicos en todos los
lugares en los que las personas pasan
varias horas en los que existe un mayor
riesgo de contaminación y la gente debe
ser vacunada y la laxitud se ve en
cualquier edad en eventos sociales
incluso los mayores bailan cerca adiós a
las mascarillas y distancias es difícil
renunciar a una nueva libertad
para terminar nuestro programa hablemos
de delicias culinarias aquí en francia
se producen más de 400 variedades de
queso y de estas el jamón ver figuraba
como el favorito de los comensales
franceses pero ese reinado llegó a su
fin porque ha sido destronado por un
queso italiano el queso mozarella todo
un cambio de tendencia inédito
las costumbres alimenticias en francia
pueden estar cambiando el queso
camembert una especialidad fabricada en
normandía y uno de los alimentos de más
tradición está siendo sustituido en la
mesa francesa y en volumen de ventas por
la mozzarella una de las razones puede
ser una variación de gusto en las nuevas
generaciones
mis abuelos comían kaman viaja a diario
al mediodía y en la noche mis padres una
vez por semana y nosotros mi generación
sobre todo durante el fin de semana sin
embargo si se consume como snack en el
aperitivo pero es cierto que hoy no
todos los franceses tienen un cambio en
su nevera
los fabricantes de queso explican que el
aumento de venta de la mozzarella es
porque también se usa para preparar una
gran variedad de comidas
nuestra relación es grande
la mozzarella es un ingrediente se
utilizó un poco como la crema de leche y
si es normal que su venta vaya en
aumento porque se utiliza en las pizzas
en los hot mess y en las ensaladas y
para gratinar no es comparable pero es
cierto que tratándose de un queso
francés estaría muy bien aumentar sus
ventas y que se consuman más cámara como
para hacer frente a esta competencia ha
comenzado a surgir un k mandar mucho más
cremoso llamado de búfala en los
almacenes especializados en queso
es un queso que está de moda todo lo que
lleva el apelativo gimv a la lo está
queremos comer quesos así cremosos algo
fácil de comer nada complicado de eso se
trata el camembert es una aventura
tienes sabor hay que tomarse su tiempo
comer un pedazo con una baguette fresca
con buen pan
las cifras hablan por sí solas desde
enero de 2021 en francia se han
consumido 33 toneladas de mozzarella
contra 29 toneladas de cambra
hasta aquí esta edición de francia en
foco gracias por acompañarnos continúen
con nuestra programación en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom